[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and what do they do when robot attacks
an innocent bystander
they charge him with battery hey well
you know we had to start off with a crap
joke because i couldn't resist or
but but this video there is a lot to
talk about amazon's invincible is now
halfway through its first season
and the show is completely kicking all
kinds of butt as we watch
mark grayson carving out a new legacy
it's full of violence
over-the-top gore and a lot of twists
and turns that completely subvert your
expectations
one of the most mysterious things going
on right now centers around the
enigmatic electric machine man robot
and throughout this video we're going to
be discussing his true plan in the
comics
and where things could be going in the
show heavy spoilers ahead for his full
arc
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you shut down now
if you enjoy the video then please click
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel to join my army
of bots
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so we first meet robot when he's
part of the team team
these are basically the invincible
version of the teen titans
and slowly throughout the season they
become some of the most respected
superhumans on the planet
when we first come across him this
seemingly synthetic superhero
shows off his super powered skill set
and instantly seems like he's easily the
mvp
because of this he's chosen by cecil
stedman to take over the guardians of
the globe
after their death at the hands of
omniman but the more and more that we
follow him the more we realize that
something else is going on
in a conversation with monster girl
robot plays his hands slightly
and drops a line about how people often
don't look past his appearance when the
pair discuss how they're often judged
because of the way they look
this line is very important for monster
girl as
she's not the teenager that she seems to
be and in the series we discover that
she's actually 29 years old
similar to this robot isn't actually a
robot and he's really a human called
rudolph connors or rudy for short
rudy suffers from a genetic condition
that means he's pretty much
allergic to oxygen and it burns his skin
when he comes into contact with it
thus rudy now lives in a specially built
pod and this strange
baby-like monster that we see at the end
of the fourth episode
is actually him and not the machine rudy
is a complete genius
and he's easily the smartest character
in the entirety of invincible
because of his incredibly high iq the
character has mastered all forms of
technology
and he's used these means to not only
keep him alive but also make it so he
can find a way to live outside the pod
able to control his machine body through
his thoughts
rudy actually has an implant in his
brain which can activate multiple
robotic drones at once
and all have them doing his bidding this
is called mechanokinesis
and it means that though he remains in
the tank at all times
he still can have an impact in the world
by using his puppets
rudy keeps up the premise of being a
machine so that people don't look too
closely at him
and slowly humanity starts to trust him
more and more as a machine
there to do their bidding however living
in a tank
and not even being able to wank takes
its toll on the character
and he longs to escape the fate that
he's been doomed to
the conversation with monster girl
clearly sparks off a desire within him
to find somewhat normality
and thus he embarks on a journey to
completely change the way things are
rudy misses being out in the world and
knows that he's pretty much gonna be
confined to this hell in a cell
is it a cell never mind confined to this
hell in a cell
until he uses his intellect to escape
now it's from this point that the molar
twins get involved
in the third episode we watched as rudy
helped them to escape from a supermax
prison
and no one of them used the other as a
human shield rudy is well aware that
they will become a pair once more
due to the reliance on two people that
most of their plans tend to have though
the molars seem like a typical hulk like
henchmen that are brawns over brains
like most things in invincible they
completely subvert expectations
the molars are experts in biology and
they're able to completely change
genomes on a molecular level and thus
they have the ability to alter whatever
life forms they wish to
in the comics they were initially set
free to resurrect the immortal
who was beheaded by nolan after he
attacked the guardians
this not only allowed rudy to further
shape the guardians but it also
confirmed for him that they were right
for his multi-phase plan
the first part of this involved finding
a suitable and desirable host
that he could clone and then take over
in the comics
and episode 4 of the season we saw him
taking a blood sample from the character
explode
rudy's true plan involves cloning rex
and at the same time
with help from the maulers he will
duplicate his mind now issue 31
makes it clear that it won't erase his
brain or transfer it
but it will create a perfect copy that
won't be able to tell the difference
this is something that is reflected in
the mullers the both of whom
constantly argue back and forth over who
the original is
on top of this he also had ulterior
motives which involved monster girl
now earlier in the comics we did
actually learn that she was attracted or
explode
but he didn't have much interest because
she seemed like a teenage girl
rudy however was interested in her and
he firstly warned the pair off one
another
as this would have caused issues with
public perception around the members
luckily for rudy rex wasn't interested
in her anyway
but that didn't mean that the former
wouldn't go above and beyond to make her
life better
rudy ended up taking a skin sample from
her in the hopes of finding a cure for
her mutation
you see with monster girl the more she
transforms
the younger she gets and thus she had
lived quite a miserable existence
constantly in fear that she was gonna
end up being a drooling mess at some
stage which
probably gonna be coming to the most of
us now there's an excellent moment in
the comics before the reveal
where monster girl suspects that rudy
might be nervous around here
and he has to keep the facade of being a
robot so that his plans go undetected
it's the classic tale of unrequited love
if one was an
ever anti-aging monster that fell in
love with her machine stalker
now not only does rudy eventually find a
way to reverse the effects on her
he also achieves his end game and with
help from the maulers
he makes a duplicate of his
consciousness in the clone of wrecks
rudy promised to pay the mullers for
their services however this was actually
a ruse
rusi like rudy and he he actually
apprehended them
once more as criminals sorry for that
crap joker's crap that
now with the job done rudy destroyed his
former body and he then started dating
monster girl
however he slowly became more and more
deranged and the longer that the comics
went on the more dangerous he got
in a cruel twist of fate rudy's brain
was actually put back
into a jar that was looked over by the
immortal though he had his consciousness
he was relegated to this prison once
more under constant watch
in case he ever tried to do anything
dangerous now there are several arcs
that all the characters go on there's
multiple timelines reboots and big
changes that subvert a lot of your
expectations which
is becoming a bit of a catchphrase and
depending on what issue of the comic you
pick up
something completely different could be
happening robot goes back and forth
between being a goodie and baddie and
because of this he easily becomes one of
the series most fascinating characters
now whether they stick with this or not
for the show remains to be seen
and i was actually surprised how early
they brought the quote-unquote clone
saga into it
as it doesn't happen until much later in
the book this means that we could get
him swapping over into his host at some
point in the season
or potentially at the end for the show's
big cliffhanger either way i can't wait
to see what happens
and hopefully you enjoy this video and
it subverted some expectations yeah
great now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the character
and what you think we're going to be
seeing in the future of the show make
sure you comment below and let me know
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on robot the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 4
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointing out all the
comic book differences so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul and i
see you next time
take care peace